let's listen to uh joe biden because
he's got more blame game going now he's
blaming texas and florida and that
desantis guy for a bunch of stuff no one
knows better than the people in this
room we have a lot more work to do a lot
more work to do i don't have to tell you
about the ultra maga agenda attacking
families and our freedoms 300
discriminatory bills introduced in
states across this country in texas
knocking on front doors to harass and
investigate parents who are raising
transgender children in florida going
after mickey mouse for god's sake
that's right close to home
but think about this
going after families knocking on doors
in texas taking transgender children
away going after mickey mouse he's such
a dis i mean this is where it's is it
like is it disingenuous is it buffoonery
does he know what he's reading i mean
the line about mickey mouse which
putting aside the glibness of the joke
it's like no he's going desantis is
going after a massive corporation that
is telling us that they're
indoctrinating children uh that's what
he's actually doing um john i'll go to
you first on this one uh desantis just
has to keep pushing pushing and pushing
right and just let this nonsense be
yeah 100 i mean look you know the
governor full disclosure i know the
governor this is an incredible
incredibly intelligent guy but the
reason that uh uh desantis terrifies the
left dave and i think you'll agree with
me
you've uh done your tour with the with
ron you've gotten to know him very well
and i think jedi and liz have gotten
this just observing him is desantis has
something trump never did desantis
understands
how to dismantle administrative state
institutions and he also understands how
evil they are
and just how damaging they are to the
fabric of america to american
traditionalism to american
exceptionalism
this is why ron desantis terrifies them
so he has to absolutely
push on he has to do more of what he's
doing and one of the things i love about
the sadness i've come to learn about him
i know a lot of his staffers this is a
guy who could not care less about a poll
politicians out there they pulled nine
different pollsters whether they should
change their tie from red to blue the
santos can make these sweeping moves
they'll go after disney in florida and
never once poll it because he knows it's
the right thing to do i think ron gets
up every day ron desantis and he says
hey look what's going to be best for my
constituents my state and the country at
large and really that's the lens through
which he makes his decisions
he's going to continue to throw him off
balance but yeah he needs to continue
right on the same path
you know can i tell you what a real deal
person he is when i had him on the tour
in orlando two weeks ago so i'm sitting
in the green room with him and i my team
walks in and i introduce him to
everybody this is this is conor this is
michael this is phoenix he goes that's
phoenix he's the guy in the book i had
told a story about phoenix who was my
intern at the time and ron the governor
had actually read the book remembered
his name and asked him about it like
that tells you this guy is legit he is
not just pretending he is paying
attention he's reading stuff like it's
real uh i want to show you a headline
from business insider because it gets to
john's point here look at this
desantis is very is a very dangerous
individual because he has already
absorbed all of the lessons of trump but
doesn't have any of the baggage an
expert on fascism argues i love these
fascism experts that they bust out all
the time they're always concerned about
people like us but is that the key point
that not only what john said that he
knows how to go in and dismantle this
stuff but he knows how to fight the
media he learned that let's say from
trump uh and he doesn't have say the
personal baggage he's married he's got a
young family all of that jedediah
yeah you know why he's very dangerous
because when someone decides to slap on
a mandate in florida he turns around and
says oh yeah that'll be 28 million
dollars that's what he does he is a man
of action and that's why i was saying
this is his moment because he didn't
just sit back a lot of governors gop
governors sat back and they said oh we
object to what the bidet administration
is doing what did you do about it this
is a guy who went in and he fought mass
mandates he fought you know vax mandates
with policy that protected people in
florida listen i interviewed i was on a
podcast a couple weeks ago the pbd
podcast and i i was just gonna mention
it i was gonna imagine it okay listen
god bless her you know bless her heart
but she actually came out and said she's
running in florida she came out and said
we should have shut down florida earlier
because then we could have stopped the
spread of covet my head nearly spun
around exorcist style when she said that
because i couldn't believe that someone
was saying that in the summer of 2022
not only that everybody moved to florida
because he didn't follow those policies
of lockdown that new york did that
california did all of those places got
buried and it's just pure idiocy
everyone you know got covered facts not
backs they're still getting it it's
everywhere so the idea that you would
have shut down earlier and stop the
spread of cover i mean this is the type
of pure sorry to say but idiotic talking
points that he's battling so this is the
guy at the moment and i think that i
think you're right i think he has a way
of dismantling media he doesn't care
what they say about him he doesn't care
it doesn't keep him up at night he's
like i'm gonna do what i have to do for
the people of florida i don't care what
you write about me he has a good retort
all the time and he gets stuff done i
like governors oftentimes because i say
they have a track record you can look at
what he did in florida and you could say
well magnify that now make him the
leader of the free world and see what
happens all these other governors asleep
at the wheel you better be paying
attention to what he just did this is
the guy i'm telling you man this is his
moment he's the guy to go against joe
biden i don't know if he wants the job i
don't know him personally but if you
guys have his ear man i'd be telling him
go for it
you